so bruising week for the prime minister
and his party
let's see what plans they have to
address those big issues
joining me now is the northern ireland
secretary brandon lewis good morning mr
lewis good morning um
can we save everybody a bit of time and
just agree that you took a major beating
in tiverton and onton
yeah there were a bad set of results for
us that does happen sometimes midterm uh
there's no denying it was a set of
results we've we've got to look
carefully out and learn from you're part
of party chairman oliver dowden resigned
in the early hours of friday morning
saying that somebody has to take
responsibility um
prime minister said again and again that
he takes responsibility for everything
that happens on his watch why is he
still there
because actually i think one of the
things we've seen in the last couple of
days is he zest and his enthusiasm and
determination to deliver for the country
we all have responsibility for the
actions you know we're all members of a
party i was in wakefield myself we all
are delivering as a government and
working to deliver as a government what
we've got to do this has happened before
where we've seen by-election results go
one way and then a following general
election go a very different way you
can't extrapolate as you know trevor a
by-election result into a general
election result it's been proven time
and again to not work that way
we've got to make sure that we're
delivering for people so come the next
general election they will vote
conservative to allow us to continue to
improve our country well you say that
but 148 back benches
think he's an albatross around your neck
and that was before last thursday and
the numbers are probably going to grow
now
this could this man could cost you your
majority and the mission which we'll no
doubt go on to talk about of all the
things you want to do high productivity
low tax and all of that
why
do you stick with boris johnson when he
could actually be
the main obstacle to you achieving the
britain you want well i've actually said
before on this show with sophia and and
elsewhere that actually i think boris
johnson is the right person to lead us
into the next general election i think
he'll do that successfully i've also i
was also clear just a few weeks ago that
those by-elections are going to be
difficult by elections let's remember
we've got a difficult backdrop in both
those seats why the by-elections came up
let alone where we are with the
pressures for people seeing with that
global challenge of inflation on the
cost of living that people are
challenged with as well as some of the
backdrop we've seen within our own party
over the last period so it's no surprise
that these are going to be a difficult
set of results what we've got to do
though is make sure that we are not just
learning from those results where of
course what we saw was a lot of people
who previously voted conservative this
time stayed home we've got to make sure
by the next general election we're
motivating those people to come out and
vote for us i do think boris johnson's
the person who can do that he's proven
that time and again where people have
written him off
both before london elections and before
even the 2019 election and then we've
been able to come back and win and win
successfully and i think he's got the
ability to do that i think we as a party
have got the message and the structure
and we'll have the plans into the next
general election to show that we've
still got things to do to help improve
our country even further yeah some of
your colleagues have pleaded with him
just at least to change the way he
presents himself in public a bit and you
know yesterday he's talking about having
a third term before anybody's given him
a second goal i mean
he's having a laugh isn't he and that
isn't that the sort of thing that really
gets people annoyed well i think you
could look at it i appreciate obviously
trevor the way you've outlined it but
what i see there is somebody and this is
what i see when i work with the prime
minister every day but it's on northern
ireland specific issues or as i remember
the cabinet and wider issues somebody's
got that drive and enthusiasm for what
we want to achieve for our country and i
think seeing that kind of zest and let's
be frank somebody who's enjoying doing
the job and wants and has got plans for
the country that he wants to deliver
having that ability to look forward i
think it's a good thing we often get
criticized let's be friends we can often
get criticized in politics so we look
short term just the next day the next
election the next vote actually we've
got somebody as prime minister who wants
to be looking long-term at how we
structurally improve our country for
generations to come that has got to be a
good thing all right well look
let me put this to you i mean um
you and oliver dowden are notoriously
seen as
the most normal members of the cabinet
and you've been loyal i think i'll say
that as a compliment
you've been loyal to the prime minister
now three years ago dowden warned that
the tories faced parliamentary
extinction in some parts of country and
she said this in the times
the conservative party is facing an
existential threat we need a leader who
can engage everywhere energetically
advocate our cause and win people over
no conservative is better placed to do
this than boris johnson now i'd like you
to compare that with what he said in his
resignation letter sent at 5 30 in the
morning on friday
our supporters are distressed and
disappointed by recent events and i
share their feelings we cannot carry on
with business as usual somebody must
take responsibility
dalton used the word extinction and what
he is essentially saying on friday is
that you face an extinction level event
you can't brush this off
well as i said you're
the head top of the program look we've
got to be clear about these were a
difficult set of results for us you do
get that midterm we've got to be focused
on delivering for people and i think one
of the points prime minister has made
over the last few days is correct us
talking about what's going on inside
westminster within a single party is
never a productive thing to do what i
get from my constituents and from people
when i talk to wherever i happen to be
in the country is they want to see
governments focused on delivering for
them and let's let's also remember
trevor if you think back even to 2017
where we had a phenomenal set of local
action results in a bad general election
you do see differences that was only a
month between them let alone the fact
that we've had a difficult set of
by-elections here we've got a period of
time to the next general election we've
got to be focused on getting things done
to make lives better for people put more
money in people's pockets grow the
economy so we have more jobs in the
economy better skilled jobs as well so
we improve productivity these are all
things we can be doing as a country
whilst we're also playing our part on
the world stage this is an impressive
effort mr lewis but um let me tell you
what your colleagues are talk looking at
they're looking at the tiverton huntsman
performance and the fact that if it
repeated across the country
several of your cabinet colleagues
including the prime minister and deputy
prime minister would be looking for new
jobs here's who's going to lose their
seats
johnson eustis sharma
rob
the real fear for you here must be
that labour party and the liberal
democrats work together and you face a
wipeout let me put it to you again
isn't it time
if you really want to protect the
conservatives mission
get your manifesto pledges done
the person who is standing in the way of
that is the prime minister
no actually i disagree
at a couple of levels first of all most
of the people who are calling uh making
criticisms on the prime minister people
who want to see him gone because they
want to win election the labour party
the liberal democrats uh people who
oppose brexit initially this is somebody
i think is capable of winning a gem
election delivering for our country as
he has done in the past look i've been
chairman of our party through difficult
elections and more successful elections
as well
you cannot extrapolate as you know a
by-election result into a general
election not least of all because even
if we look at tibetan the liberal
democrat vote in itself went up
marginally what we've got to do is
motivate those people who didn't come
and vote who usually would vote for us
to come back and vote for us
as i've said to you trevor i'm not i'm
not i'm not underscored that's a bad
result what we've got to do is encourage
and give a reason to those people in a
general election to come back and vote
for us that's about delivering over the
next year or two and then about showing
that our plans for the following
parliament are exciting plans to take
our country forward and boris johnson's
the person who can do it all right
before we get on to those exciting plans
let me just have one last batch of that
this prime minister says he's now
thinking about his third term um would
you felt happier if he said yesterday
that uh as tony blair did more or less
in in 2005
that uh he wants to be clear that this
next election will be the last he will
lead uh conser the conservative party
into and after that
he's gone
no and david cameron did a similar thing
if you remember there's a huge amount of
pharaoh around that afters what i want
is a prime minister who is not thinking
about the next few months but it's
thinking about that long-term change we
need in our country so you'll have to
deliver you'll be going on and on and on
as they say look
i'm very clear i want our country to
have a conservative-led government for a
very very long time i want a prime
minister who's looking at the long-term
and doing so with enthusiasm and focus
that's what we've got in boris johnson
and that's why i support him and we'll
continue to all right well look let me
um
let me give up on that one to some
extent and take the prime minister's
point that um he thinks people are
harshly sick of hearing about him and
what that what they really care about is
policy on jobs and costs of living and
so on so let's talk about how you're
doing on all that um
strikes this week uh there's probably
come more coming down the track is there
any resolution to the rail dispute
inside
well i hope there is obviously this is
an issue between the employer and the
unions uh but i think for for people
across the country we want to see a
resolution to this people being
disrupted getting to school getting to
medical appointments getting to work
that isn't good for the railways even
where we've seen this roughly 25 drop in
use of railways through covid as people
have had obviously pressures of covid
and coming back to work and change of
how they they work having further
pressure on that where people start to
see the railways as unreliable is not a
good thing for the railway particularly
we want to encourage people to be using
public transport so i hope we do see an
end to this um and i think that's what's
in the best interest of the country as
well you say you hope you want to see an
end to it um
and your colleagues have been saying
this week this the negotiations nothing
really to do with ministers it's between
the employers and the unions um would it
be helpful if there were less colorful
language from some of your colleagues
grant shapz accused the unions of i'm
quoting here gunning for a strike
called under false presences
uh
you're trying to turn an industrial
dispute into political showdown aren't
you no but equally i think it is right
that we as government ministers are very
clear and give a guide to the public
about what we think on these issues that
affect them this is a government of
course that's investing 96 billion
pounds into rail infrastructure we
supported the railways and actually all
of us trevor ui and everybody watching
this program put in support worth about
600 pound per household into the
railways through kobe to keep them going
so he's right that we air in the
opinions we hear from our constituents
and as a government around why this is
the wrong thing to do we should not be
having a strike we should be seeing this
but aren't you just giving mr mick lynch
the railway uh workers leader the
opportunity to
make the point that he constantly makes
but this is really nothing to do with
the employers and that the government
minister government's ministers are
pulling the strings so every time mr
chaps gets into it uh mr mr lynch smiles
and says
tell you who's in charge here but they
won't talk to us
well i think you see it's factually not
true it's the union that's calling the
strikes they're meant to be negotiating
with the employers we as a government
the ones putting this record levels in
investment into the railway services and
improving it modernizing it and i think
it is right that we're clear with the
public as i say when we've seen this 25
drop we're seeing more people who do use
railways using them in a way that uses
their mobile phones etcetera so you've
got some of those ticket offices now
issuing less than one ticket an hour
that isn't a way to run a modern railway
it's right that we're putting the
investment in to support that change
what you're doing
you're doing it again you've just done
it you've just started to express a view
about what should be a subject of
negotiation
what i've just outlined you is a factual
position of where we are with the
railways and the development with the
railways and the government's massive
record levels of investment billions and
billions of pounds to improve our
railways for people's use in the future
for people to use it they need to be
confident in it that means it means it
needs to be reliable that's partly our
investment but it's also the unions
making sure that the railways are
running and trains can run on time all
right there's more coming down the track
uh british airways have voted for a
strike postal workers teachers doctors
even
barristers um
what's your plan are you
making it clear to everybody you're not
going to get inflation rises
well we've got to be we have been very
clear we've got to be very conscious and
careful with this is about taxpayers
money and making sure we're not doing
things that further drive inflation if
anything we want to be looking at what
we can do to hold and pull inflation
back to more reasonable levels this is a
global challenge we're seeing countries
all over the world with these pressures
on inflation we've got to make sure
we're not doing things that further
drive that at the same time as
recognizing that we as a gun want to do
everything we can to support people but
of course this is all taxpayer money and
it's right that the chancellor looks at
that very very carefully so to be clear
none of these people is going to get an
inflation level
uh
uh
pay increase none of them is going to be
in the seven to nine percent range well
there's a whole range of decisions for
different sectors and we saw nurse
obviously last year got a pay rise but
let's be very clear trevor we're looking
at a structure so for example with the
rmt and the railway workers the median
wage in that sector is about 44 000
pounds we're seeing train drivers on 56
and even 70 000 with overtime compared
to an average wage of 26 000. i don't
think many people will feel barristers
are particularly underpaid i think
someone who qualified as one a long time
ago
so i think we've got to be clear about
doing what is right for the country as a
whole and being careful with and looking
carefully how we spend taxpayers money
all right well let's look at the country
as a whole energy costs up food costs up
taxes up the increases in pensions and
wages are about to be wiped out by this
double-digit inflation um where is the
good news for the british people in all
of that well these are challenging times
there's no getting away but what are you
doing about it well where's the good
news no that's a fair question trevor so
this is a challenging period of time as
i said we're seeing global pressure from
as we're coming out of kovid as we're
seeing actually the food pressure
particularly from that war in ukraine
putin's abhorrent invasion of ukraine is
putting huge pressure on food supplies
and governments all around the world are
dealing with it so what we have been
doing is we've been putting a very
substantial package of support for
people that's worth about 37 billion
pounds so about 8 million of the most
vulnerable households in the country are
going to have support to around 1200
pounds this year alone the chancellor is
obviously carefully looking at this for
decisions that he'll be making in the
next few months around what more if
anything we can do and how we do that in
a way that really directly helps people
whether it's about keeping the cost of
fuel down and as somebody represents a
part of the country a lot of my
constituents is on old fired central
heating i understand that pressure
and we want to do what we can support
people that's why that 37 billion pound
package of support has already got it
some of which of course hasn't quite got
to people yet it's in july for example
the national insurance threshold change
will help people with a reduction in
their tax payments but
as you say it hasn't got there yet it
isn't
getting into people's pockets there is
still the situation where people feel uh
poorer and it's puzzling you spent 400
billion plus and covid and we know all
of that that
everybody kind of agrees that was a good
thing to do
it's probably you can't spend find
another 10 billion or so to meet some of
the pay demands that would help to
offset uh those cost of living increases
well that's the balance the the
challenge the decisions the chancellor
has to make my economic degree is a very
very long way behind me now but even i
know trevor one of those uh one of the
realities of the challenge is to say
we've got the national insurance
threshold change coming in in july that
will see people getting that tax
reduction across the country but what
you also find is because of what we've
done through kovid we have got more debt
in the country that we've got to manage
and the decision a chance has to make
when using taxpayers money is not
putting up debt further of course
our children our grandchildren's
generations will then have to pay off
and equally not putting things into the
economy that further drive up inflation
we want to see inflation coming down
this is a global challenge there's no
getting away from that but we also want
to be able to make sure we're doing this
within our means so that you know we
can't continue to just print money
because that drives not only further
inflation but debt for the future so
there are difficult balances that chance
has to make i think he is doing that in
a way that works with people across the
country and helps them have ultimately
more money in their pocket all right
well look um
obviously chancellor is not going to
move uh on this let's uh talk to the
talk about the dilemma and one of your
other colleagues faces faces you're
sending asylum seekers to rwanda polling
tells us is probably quite a popular
policy with a lot of people
um but you haven't actually managed to
ship a single individual to kigali um
even when people like your policies you
can't actually execute them
well look one of the things we said this
is always going to be one of the changes
we have with illegal immigration
sometimes is the way our processes work
i was immigration minister for a while
myself a few years ago and i can
remember having times where we were
trying to
deport even foreign national offenders
and at the very last minute and there's
a tactic that some of these people will
use where literary is on the plane they
will then get the lawyers to go and
claim asylum or something so that
doesn't mean they're going to succeed
these people
illegal these are people these are
illegal
likely to be asylum seekers you know
these are people who have come here
illegally and in the case i'm talking
about sometimes these are even foreign
national offenders where they can run an
appeal at the very last moment that
means that you have to go back and start
again doesn't mean they're going to win
that appeal and it is right that we have
brought in place a policy and i think
the chance the so the home secretary and
the prime minister deserve great credit
for bringing forward a policy that he's
actually very clearly seeking to break
the business policy but you haven't
actually done it and there's no sign
you're going to be able to well first we
have brought the policy and you're quite
right the courts have decided that they
that we've got to um go through this
process of this appeal they haven't said
that what we've done is is wrong and i'm
confident eventually we will see people
moving to rwanda and it is right of
course that when people come to this
country they do it in a legal means it's
not people putting people's lives at
risk and importing means that people
here legally can get the proper support
that they need okay look i i i'm really
trying to find out
when you're actually going to get going
on on doing things now there's an
interesting thing well hold on so trevor
just be clear we have got going on this
it's not the government that has
prevented this flight from going back to
iran no but that's a court decision okay
let's deal with another uh issue which
is now the business business secretary's
uh business i understand now that the
government is considering uh putting um
new tariffs on import and steel um
and that will mainly affect some
developing countries now this isn't
first of all is it going to be is that
true and secondly if it is true
that's not very friendly to the
developing countries who want to export
their steel and um
for global britain which needs all the
friends it can get it's not very smart
foreign policy is it oh we are a global
country you know as you've seen we've
been working with partners around the
world not just on ukraine but on trade
deals as well and one of the things in
the business secretary the chancellor
the prime minister have to look at all
times is getting the balance between how
we trade with our international partners
and also making sure we give the best
opportunity to uk-based industries and
businesses to be able to grow to be
sustainable and and to deliver and
create security and supply whether it's
for food whether it's for energy and
infrastructure here in this country so
look these new tariffs on steel
could be a possibility i'm not saying
look i'm not saying they could be i'm
not saying they won't be i'm saying as a
government we are always looking at what
we do to get the balance right between
our international trade our work with
our international partners and what's
right for the uk
okay look let's um the deal find if i
may with your own territory um
any progress on resolving the
differences over the northern ireland
protocol yet well we're going to have
the legislation will be brought in for
what we call second reading the debate
will be in parliament tomorrow uh the
foreign secretary myself will be leading
that work uh through parliament tomorrow
so look i think that is the start of
seeing a resolution to the problems
around the northern ireland protocol
that is going to resolve the very issues
that have been so detrimentally
effective
no we're not actually we're very much
fixing the problems within the protocol
particularly with the way that the eu
have wanted to see it implemented that's
caused that has caused substantial
problems for businesses in great britain
not supplying northern ireland and
businesses and constituencies and
communities in online not being able to
access the products they need even the
jewish community technically can't
practice their religion because of the
eu's requirements that's not acceptable
but you see what the problem is here i
mean we've been talking about all the
things the government says it wants to
do
uh and it feels like
at best your law lord frost described
the northern ireland protocol uh as
unfinished business um you got brexit
done uh but you didn't actually and your
answer to the failure of the policy
it seems to be to abandon the deal that
you yourselves signed so even where you
won even where you've got the policy
this government seems to be ready to
snatch defeat from the jaws of victory i
mean
it's a government of paralysis isn't it
two things in that trevor first of all i
think that's a very unfair and a
misrepresentation of the reality of the
protocol the problem of the protocol is
the way the eu wants to see it
implemented and i think actually as a as
a government it would be wrong of us to
leave a situation in north ireland that
isn't working there is no political
leader in any party in northern who says
the protocol is working the unionist
community in northern fundamentally do
want the protocol removed what we are
doing is fixing the problems within the
protocol about how it's being
implemented so that businesses can
prosper again so people of northern who
at the moment for example can't even
benefit from the chancellor's decisions
on vat and fuel tax that have helped
people across the rest of the uk we
can't implement in northern ireland
because of the way the protocol works
we've got to fix that for the people in
northern ireland and ultimately i want
to see the uh re-establishment of the
north island assembly and the executive
the protocol is getting in the way of
that and that's why it's breaching the
belfast good friday agreement we've got
to resolve that that's what this
legislation will do but ultimately we
want to do this by agreement with the eu
but to do that they need to show some
flexibility and actually come and
negotiate in a flexible way
you see what the problem is here i mean
the prime minister says oh stop talking
about me uh let's get on to the things
that matter but on almost everything and
i don't
challenge your good will on this but
almost everything you've said to me
yes we've got plans yes it's going to
happen but it's all jam tomorrow not
delivery today and isn't that the real
problem of a johnston administration
that talks a great game but we're still
to see the results on any of these
things and we haven't even talked about
leveling up well actually i'll challenge
that trevor because what i've talked
about today is 96 billion pounds we are
investing in our railways with the 37
billion pounds we have already putting
and are putting in to support people and
with the northern ireland protocol it's
about actually fixing the issue around
what the eu have put in place we are
doing that in fact we'll be in
parliament moving that legislation
tomorrow in the next 24 hours we are
very much getting on with the job
brandon lewis thank you very much indeed
thank you